we're just talking about concerts coming
up this summer reg last concert you went
to last concert I went to God it's been
a while um Wow I I truly cannot remember
the last concert I've been to it's been
that long so there's it's back to my
playing days I know it's been that long
who is touring this this summer uh it's
time for me to get to a concert who are
you gonna go see this summer I don't
know if I'm gonna I think I'm not gonna
go out of my way I don't know I dunno
wait I just did I have seen someone yes
I just remember Janet Jackson in Hawaii
yes Janet Jackson last year in Hawaii oh
yeah
JJ fantastic did you talk you know how
bit I did not talk to her
it was it was I was back to my 1986 UCLA
dorm self watching the pleasure
principle video yeah she she put on all
the hits it was great yeah Janet Jackson
you know in Hawaii too so that was a
plus in Hawaii awesome love you JJ but
if you had to see that's one of those
where even if you had a chance to talk
to her you can't really talk to her as a
fanboy with her brother right would you
know - no absolutely not okay because
she deserves look she has a pretty good
resume herself and everyone had a Janet
Jackson crush growing up in my era she
was Beyonce before Beyonce would you
rather have dated Janet or met Michael
you're killing me here
you're killing me here aren't you JJ you
are fine but I'm sorry it is the glove
one the best song he ever did was
I like old school shake your body down
to the ground can you feel it you know I
liked when he was a part of the the
Jackson 5 okay with his brothers but you
can never go wrong with smooth criminal'
that is probably my sons and I song in
the car on the way to school
smooth criminal' I got him hooked on
Michael Jackson my life is complete as a
father can you moonwalk I used to be
able to I don't think my my legs and my
feet work the same anymore but I thought
I did a pretty good moonwalk I'm older
than you
I can still moonwalk yes of course I can
next time I'm in the New York studio
we're having a Mike Jackson day and
we're gonna dress up we're gonna play
we're gonna moonwalk we're gonna do it
all no no no I'm not dressing up I'll
just oh why not
why not if we're gonna do it let's do it
I like that I like yeah I think I can
get there one eighty all right let's
talk some basketball
if you were Carmelo Anthony you would do
what you got where do I sign in because
he has a he has the right to opt into
his what is it 28 28 no one's gonna give
him 28 no no no but he could stay there
but but if he wanted to win and take
less now I said the same thing he's
gonna take 28 million and play in
Oklahoma City and then after that is
when he might opt in to play for
somebody Houston is a perfect system for
him doesn't have to play any defense and
he'd just jack up threes is Houston
going to won him a year from now that's
the big question that's the big question
well certainly hopefully his talents
won't deteriorate anymore from what we
saw in the playoffs but just to be a
spot-up shooter again that's the last
thing to leave you that's a perfect
system for them
the Cavs limp in crawl in scratch into
round 2 here
it feels like Toronto is is the best
matchup for them and the second round as
opposed to Philadelphia maybe even
Boston for that matter but why what do
you expect to happen this time around
with this the artist formerly known as
the cabs taking on the rep
well LeBron James and company and the
Cavs they've had to Ronald's numbers
over the last few seasons so I think
it's like a lot to be going to this
series that's the edge they have
personally I believe Toronto will win
the series probably in six just for the
simple fact I think the Cavs are going
to wear down and fan in LeBron look how
much work he had to do in a seven-game
series to get out of the first round and
he was unbelievable yesterday in Game
seven I mean that's when you talk about
your best player setting the tone for a
game seven that's what you want to see
so he did absolutely everything he
played heavy minutes in round one and
what Dwayne Casey and the Raptors have
going for them is that they played nine
players they they're very deep and
arrested and I just think the Cavs are
gonna wear down now can Kevin Love and
green and George Hill play like they
played in Game seven perhaps but we
didn't see that in round one so why
would we see that in round two I just
think they wear down and I think Toronto
wins in six do you make anything of this
when you play with the great players
sometimes you you watch the great player
and it feels like the Cavs I don't know
if they have a game plan on the
offensive end I really I really don't it
just feels like they're like what's
LeBron gonna do here and then they sort
of adapt to that is that what happens I
think we saw probably a little bit of
that in the first few games in that
Indiana series again the veteran showed
up in Game seven with it when they need
it in the most but those guys are gonna
have to play like that if they want to
continue to advance and play the winner
of that Boston Philly matchup
LeBron needs help LeBron can't be
playing 43 to 44 minutes in his 15th
season
during the playoffs I mean you've got to
cut his Minister yeah you know it it's
the workload is way too much Daniel and
God bless him that he's able to do that
but when you're going to get the number
one seed in Toronto and a team that
plays nine and ten players and they they
could throw a lot of bodies at him and
sooner or later that tree is gonna fall
they're just trying to chop the tree
down who do you like
emerging from the East Philadelphia
well you're all in I'm all in yes
especially they got the size they got
the passing they've got the shooting
people are not talking about the
shooting now with Belinelli JJ Redick I
think Ilyas ovo all those guys were
fantastic pickups a veteran leadership
off the bench in the locker room on the
bus on the plane and you just got young
young studs and indeed and Simmons who
are playing probably the best basketball
of a lot of players in these last so I'm
all-in with Philly
god bless Boston getting there after a
tough seven-game series with Milwaukee
but I just think they're gonna be
overmatched a versus Philly you think
the Greek freak stays in Milwaukee I
hope so
but I'm sure there's gonna be a lot of
teams offering here offering him
everything he doesn't seem like a big
city guy and again I've you know talked
to a woman a few occasions and he seems
very reserved a lot like a quite Leonard
I thought quite literal was gonna finish
his career in San Antonio but that has
it seems to be the case I don't know if
a big city is calling him but I always
tell people the grass is not always
greener you know you want to go to New
York Chicago LA well there's a lot of
expectations that come with that you
know you play in Milwaukee it's a one
newspaper town and you can rule the
roost and the grass is not always
greener if you're thinking about that
yeah you can probably get paid and do
more endorsements and all that but I
mean if you can make Milwaukee a winner
my goodness that's that's pretty special
James Harden yesterday
kind of did whatever James Hardin wanted
to do more impressed with what Hardin
did or I guess LeBron with the game
seven
but I mean Hardin does he makes it look
kind of easy
LeBron looks like he's always working
whereas it doesn't seem like hardens
working that hard is that family that's
very fair key word easy I mean that was
that 41 points 7 for 12 from deep I mean
it's almost like he was moonwalking and
doing that in his sleep and we saw that
in Game one in that first round matchup
as well I think that caught Utah guard I
think they were still in their home run
trot after beating OKC I think we'll
probably see a better game on Wednesday
from the Jazz but I don't know if anyone
has any answers for the bearded one
because he is playing at such a high
that's why it's so difficult I go back
and forth with his MVP because what
LeBron did in a game 7 atmosphere yeah
and how he started that game what was he
like 8 for 8 9 for 9 or something like
that it was just ridiculous
so I mean you get that awesome
at the end of the day I do believe
Harden will win the MVP because of his
body his body of resume over the last
three years
runner up two of the last three years
but what LeBron has done in his 15 two
years simply outstanding and JJ reddick
on last week and we were talking he was
in my dream he was helping me with my
jump shot cuz I didn't know anybody else
who had a great jump shot so I had JJ
Redick join me out okay and I said to
Redick best jump shot in the game and he
didn't even hesitate you know who he
took Thompson yeah he say - he said it's
there's no wasted movement no nothing it
just it's perfect catch shoot his elbow
was in you know beautiful release
rotation beautiful gooseneck on the
follow-through
uses his legs not a lot but uses them a
little bit I would concur I would
probably go with the clay as well in
terms of
jump shooting form follow-through and
salad a lot of people forget it he has
great balance as well why didn't we see
that in college you saw it in glimpses
why do we you had to go out of your way
to watch Washington State watch it just
right I mean that conference was all
about Oregon and UCLA at the time well
but you would think that that size with
that pedigree that people would have
looked at him instead of where he fell
to the wall they did he was a lottery
pick so they did see him yeah but he
played for Washington State who went in
front of Pauly can you pull up who went
in front of klay Thompson in in that
drive do you remember reg motley my
thing is how did he get to Washington
State and I say UCLA playing down there
in the OC like who's doing the
recruiting was that Ben Howland at the
time but I mean are you kidding me how
good was he in high school
I don't care he played at what like
modder day or one of those big
high-profile schools but he had polling
hold on the pedigree Michael Tighe no I
know I know I agree I know maybe you
should have gone to Minnesota didn't
Michael his dad go to Minnesota I
wouldn't go that far
all right Paulie who went before clay
times 2011 draft Kyrie Irving Derek
Williams Arizona
Enes Kanter Tristan Thompson Jonas
Valanciunas Yann Vesely Bismack Biyombo
Brandon Knight Kemba Walker Jimmer
Fredette let's read let's read draft
that he would be probably behind Kyrie
Kyrie would still probably be number one
and then you could go with clay it's out
of that time you went number what eight
or nine seven where did clay go point xi
oh my good now yeah so barely a lottery
pick
would you take kemmal Walker who's nine
which one do you think Jimmer Fredette
went ahead of him yes whoever won
come on man I don't care but to who
Sacramento I think took Jimmer Fredette
Kawhi Leonard went 15
Jimmy Butler went 30 yeah so if I
redraft the
is Jimmy Butler better than klay
Thompson oh my goodness yeah I just well
no cause clays a pretty good defender as
well that's that's very difficult that's
a that's a difficulty you're on the
clock you get you get you could take
Jimmy Butler or klay Thompson you got to
make a pick and I'm golden state or
anything any team I would probably go
with Jimmy Butler but clay fits perfect
for that system with Steph dream on and
Katie I don't know Golden State has the
same success Jimmy Butler's on that team
would you take Kawhi Leonard over those
two guys klay Thompson and Jimmy Butler
well Kauai am i right here you're
drafting the Finals MVP I mean what
quiet I want to get I'm just saying if
we redrafted is what we said so is Kyrie
going one if we read rap I got quiet
agree we'll always be one okay this I
like how he is oh it's always one then
Kawhi I'm going I'm going
Kyrie Jimmy Butler Wow
clay Oh
Kawhi just for the simple fact I need to
know where quiet head is and then Jimmer
Fredette goes after that no Tristan
Thompson hey hey Tristan Thompson played
huge stop he's a max guy in they get you
know they got this contract for him and
then he hadn't done anything so we we're
supposed to be supposed to play well but
he played well in Game seven
all right where the hell's he been
maternity leave I could tell you where
he's in the club
[Laughter]
Patrick that's not readily millet Sophie
don't be adding meat on Twitter Chloe
knows I've got her back
I love Chloe I have fun in in Houston
their rent thank you I appreciate it
that's Reggie Aloysius Miller jr. that
there for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]